donc en octobre dernier j'ai écrit un
article dans le monde sur une super
intelligent ce qui était un article qui
faisait vraiment à kapitalis de pas mal
de choses qui se disent j'ai parmi les
gens qui réfléchissent à ce genre de
questions notamment sur la sphère l'a
souvent bien sûr dans le livre super
intelligent sous des gens qui réfléchit
un peu à ça histoire trop se valent tous
sa future blaye fait une située au fitur
violaine et institute bref il ya
beaucoup de gens qui réfléchissent à ça
et beaucoup de gens qui ont les
réflexions que j'ai partagé dans cet
article qui vraiment on se repose
essentiellement sur des observations
d'heuliez at elle qui a déployé
aujourd'hui qui sont absolument provence
ul et également sur un article
un sondage qui a été fait auprès des
chercheurs on y en a qui lui aussi est
basse et c'est la vie des chercheurs
donc c'est quelque chose de relativement
consensuelle par se casser
donc c'est ce qui émerge du sondage des
chercheurs et du coup j'ai l'impression
de ne pas dire quoi que ce soit de très
controversés
monsieur c'est que si j'avais très
controversé est néanmoins ça m'a valu
beaucoup de réactions très très très
négatives voire extrêmement virulente
voire tout simplement méchante et gelé
très mal pris elles sont fines sacrés
sheets forme sur twitter que ce pas
commis
[Musique]
alors du coup suite à la crise tant que
j'ai reçu à ce sujet bah j'ai créé un
mal prise et j'ai pas mal des prix mais
on voit la passe était très très mal
pendant plusieurs heures pendant trois
jours en fait j'étais triste énervé
déprimé j'avais envie d'abandonner cette
quête de sensibiliser les gens est-ce
que déçu d'une sur intelligence et
j'étais très très mal mais c'est
vraiment dommage parce que pendant du
coup trois jours chez rien foutu ah oui
au fait je suis à l'université mohamed 6
de polytechnique pour une confiance que
je vais donner
et du coup c'est l'occasion de visiter
ce tout nouveau bâtiment français il ya
quelques années maintenant mais maroc
cette nouvelle université
certes il aurait dû permettre de faire
un teaser alors si je devais parler à
mon choix du passé je commencerai par
les dire que je comprends tout à fait la
situation se prendre une chine comme
c'est très très difficile et chris sa
part est un
un élément qui justifie totalement trois
jours d'inactivité ou de quasi
inactivité
mais avec le recul est notamment après
avoir lu ce super livre de david byrne
ce feeling good je me dis que finalement
ça se tristesse son inactivité et son
honnête homme motionnaire bah finalement
il n'était pas si justifiée en tout cas
il n'était pas désirable
c'est finalement une mauvaise chose que
pendant plusieurs jours j'ai été
complètement inactif et est bon à rien
alors dit comme ça vous avez peut-être
l'impression que je suis ultra difficile
avec le mois du passé mais comme
l'expliqué très bien david byrne en fait
la raison de mon agacement de
gouvernements et de ma tristesse et bien
réfléchir c'était pas seulement due à
des forces externes mais c'était aussi
dû au fait que je m'attendais à
certaines choses une certaine forme de
réaction et j'avais l'impression que les
chercheurs en intelligence artificielle
devait avoir une certaine modestie
épistémique et déferré leur jugement à
l'avis de leurs pairs au consensus qui
émerge de ce sondage de leur père est
également j'avais l'impression que des
gens aussi informé
devait pas être aussi violent qui l'ont
été parce qu'en apparaît déjà dans de
précédents je faisais une confusion
entre le monde tel qu'il devait être
selon une idéologie son nom sur mon
idéal et le monde tel qu'il est
effectivement et c'est cette tension
entre ce que je pensais que le monde
devait être et le monde tel qu'il est
qui est finalement la cause de mon air
vraiment parce que je pensais que l'on
devait vraiment être que l'équipe devait
être sauf que non le monde il est tel
qu'il est il faut prendre le monde tel
qu'il est et une fois que l'on se dise
ah bah il faut prendre de fait ces
attaques parfois personnelles très
violente comme étant une information qui
mêle à jour nos croyances sur eux
qu'elle est vraiment l'état du monde
comment les gens réagissent à telle ou
telle information ait utilisé ça pour
améliorer notre compréhension du monde
mais si on considère que cette tension
entre le monde tel qu'il devrait être à
tel qu'il est il qu'elle fût c'est
quelque chose auquel il faut s'attendre
parce que le monde n'a pas à être telle
qu'on aimerait qu'il soit si on prend ça
comme en fait simplement ben y'a pas
besoin de s'énerver il n'y a pas de
raison d'être
de plus énervé que ça outre mesure mais
surtout la question qui est vraiment
pertinente dans un optique notamment de
prison civilement et de bien-être
personnel
c'est finalement la question est ce que
ma tristesse et ma déception
mon énervement est ce que toutes ces
émotions étaient finalement quelque
chose de désirable est-ce que c'était
une bonne chose pour moi et pour le
monde va dire que je sois complètement
inactif pendant trois jours il me semble
que la réponse à ces questions cac40
donc en tout cas j'ai pas aimé être
inactif avoir ce sentiment d'être bon à
rien pendant trois jours et j'aurais
préféré être toujours aussi motivés et
toujours aussi jovial est toujours aussi
déterminé à faire en sorte que le monde
allait aussi bien que possible et que je
sois personnellement le content de moi
épanoui et heureux
bref tout ça ça m'amène à une idée qui
de david byrne ce qui finalement ne peut
paraître assez bizarre mais qui me
semble un crabe le mans pertinente
en y réfléchissant qui est le fait que
l'on peut choisir nos émotions cercle
émotion c'est pas forcément de quelque
chose qui nous tombe dessus
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut maîtriser
plus ou moins et en particulier on peut
choisir les émotions qui nous sont
utiles et préférait avoir ses émotions
utile et désirable plutôt que d'avoir
des émotions qui sont inutiles ni
désirable donc typiquement je pense que
pour l'apprentissage des maths
une émotion qui est absolument
indispensable pour la motivation pour
faire du bien dans la société
une émotion qui est absolument
indispensable et qui est en plus
extrêmement désirable
c'est le fait d'avoir un super
engouement avoir simplement être
passionné par ces sujets et je suis
rentré temps ce en quoi j'ai tout le
monde à cultiver ce sentiment parce que
c'est quand même déjà cool d'être
passionné d'être heureux et en plus être
passionné pour ces sujets là en
particulier se sont pour le futur de
l'humanité par exemple c'est souvent une
très bonne chose d'être métier pour ça
puisque ça va nous motiver à faire des
actions qui sont globalement bénéfique
contrario il ya des émotions qui sont
assez clairement des fastes y compris
pour soi même et pour les actions que
l'on aura pour améliorer l'intérêt du
monde
par exemple la dépression est souvent
quelque chose qui n'est pas forcément
agréable de ressentir donc si on peut
chercher à contrôler cette émotion à -
la ressentir
bah c'est quelque chose qui est
désirable pour soi nba
je pense que cette situation allait
assez exagéré c'est pas si facile que ça
mais il ya quelque chose de cet ordre
d'idées que l'on peut cultiver chez nous
juste cultiver cette émotion positive
qui est se sentir bien se sentir heureux
se sentir motivé je pense que c'est une
émotion qui est beaucoup plus désirable
et on peut la choisir on peut chercher
un enfer à faire en sorte de la
ressentir de façon proactive dans ce
sens on peut un peu court circuiter
notre cerveau essayer de faire en sorte
que nos cerveaux sont davantage
sensibles à ce genre d'émotion et
cherche davantage à ressentir ce genre
d'émotion mais aussi de façon un peu
plus subi on va dire on peut choisir un
peu plus notre environnement par exemple
de choisir de suivre les personnes de
regarder des vidéos qui ont tendance à
augmenter notre niveau de bonheur aux
dépens de vidéos qui ont tendance à
mettre dans émotions qui ne sont pas
désirable et c'est en fait assez
clairement à titre personnel c'est
quelque chose que je fais et que je
cherche à faire de plus en plus
typiquement quand je me sent déprimé
pour une raison x y et z et que je me
sens complètement nul
inactif et que j'ai l'impression d'avoir
envie de rien faire
bah c'est là que j'ai envie de me
remonter le moral en prend tous rangs
des trucs beaucoup plus enthousiasmant
beaucoup plus motivant et ce qu'ils font
là que je regardais présente des vidéos
de michael dell passe quand même classe
comme lieu c'est quand même plutôt joli
enfin il ya des émotions sur lesquels
parfois sont positives parfois sont
négatifs et faut vraiment réfléchir à
quand est-ce qu'il faut les avoir et je
pense que c'est là que c'est vraiment
intéressant de faire attention à ses
émotions est vraiment de les choisir par
exemple la colère qui est un sentiment
qui est l'indignation même temps que ce
sont des sentiments qui qui ont beaucoup
gagné à cause des réseaux sociaux vont
vers cette vidéo est aussi jpy gray qui
explique pourquoi sur ce genre
d'émotions je pense que c'est vraiment
fort en voir au cas par cas parce que
bien souvent ces émotions sont en fait
contre-productive quand on est énervé
c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
réfléchir et donc quand on est sur des
causes qui sont un tant soit peu
compliqué pas c'est important quand même
moins temps en temps prendre le temps de
bien réfléchir à ces sujets parce que
c'est souvent très compliqué du coup on
va faire attention à cette émotion mais
je comprends tout à fait que parfois ça
soit des mes émotions qu'ils soient
excellents productive qui permettent par
exemple
de se motiver ou sinon de rallier
d'autres gens à notre cause donc ça peut
être des émotions positives mais c'est
important de choisir ses émotions et de
foi en quoi et à quel moment ces
émotions sont positives pour les avoir
et à quel moment en fait elles sont
contre-productives et si elles sont trop
positifs on peut simplement cherché à ne
pas avoir ses émotions
bref ça peut paraître assez bizarre mais
je pense que on est vraiment au moins
partiellement contrôle de nos émotions
du coup il faut que c'est vraiment une
bonne idée que de réfléchir à nos
émotions et d'essayer de choisir les
émotions qui nous sont désirables et
utile